première journée de tournage à hong kong
une journée de fou il fait une chaleur
accablante ici plus de 30 degrés à midi
devait faire 35 degrés c'est extrêmement
humide mais au moins il ne pleuvait pas
aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut même plus
quand on travaille à l'extérieur surtout
qu'il a plu abondamment au cours des
derniers jours alors la ville est assez
calme de grandes manifestations
aujourd'hui pas d'affrontements entre
policiers et manifestants
en fait on s'est promené dans des
quartiers assez populaire et les
commerçants se plaignaient justement du
manque d'activité parce qu'à cause des
manifestations il ya beaucoup moins de
touristes sont tous les touristes qui
viennent de la chine continentale ici et
comme ils ne viennent pas à cause des
manifestations de ça fait vraiment
baisser le chiffre d'affaires certains
disaient qu'ils avaient perdu 80 % de
leur chiffre d'affaires depuis quelques
semaines donc une ambiance un peu morose
milan quartier des affaires quand même
c'est toujours aussi occupé parce que la
vie continue
évidemment les médias on se concentre
beaucoup sur ce qui se passe ces
manifestations les manifestants les
protestataires
mais dans les faits quand même c'est
vie continue ici à hong kong c'est une
ville d'ailleurs très très vivante du
matin jusqu'au soir parce que là il est
déjà presque 11 heures du soir et encore
beaucoup beaucoup de monde dans les rues
donc on a profité pour faire des
entrevues en a fait cinq aujourd'hui ça
a été assez vite assez occupés on a
parlé d'abord à une
une femme de 43 ans mère de deux enfants
qui est devenu un peu un des visages de
cette mobilisation
parce qu'elle s'est interposé entre la
police et des manifestants et la vidéo
de cet affrontement est devenue virale
ici danthine à l'eau qui est devenu un
peu une célébrité nous a raconté à quel
point il avait été choqué par la
violence policière c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui la pousse à continuer à participer à
ce mouvement qu'elle juge extrêmement
important pour un pont ensuite une
entrevue avec un libraire indépendant
quelques libraires indépendants ici ce
sont surtout des grandes chaînes de
librairies qui appartiennent en fait
qu'ils sont contrôlés par le
gouvernement chinois
donc ils vont nous expliquer un peu ce
que c'est que la l'ingérence de pékin au
jour le jour dans la vie au congrès
parce que maintenant très difficile
d'obtenir certains livres par exemple
des livres sur ce qui s'est passé à la
place tiananmen
189 bien des livres c'est mentionné
féminisme révolution bien plus difficile
à trouver donc ces libraires continue
d'avoir ses livres dans leur librairie
mais ils craignent évidemment ce qui
pourrait arriver si jamais 7,7 de loi
d'extradition est votée par le parlement
ici a encore ensuite rencontre avec une
icône un peu de la démocratie ici un
militant de longue date martin vie qui
qui est un défendeur et fondateur du
mouvement pro démocratie ici qui nous a
parlé de sa vision des protestataires
il a même défendu la violence parce
qu'il dit bien que ça a c'est quand même
bouger un peu le gouvernement les
autorités ici il en faut malheureusement
parce que hillion kong et en sont rendus
là et puis à un moment assez fascinant
rencontre avec deux jeunes
protestataires 23 ans des femmes qui en
sont à leur premier engagement politique
alors c'était vraiment intéressant de
les entendre nous expliquer pourquoi
elles ont décidé de se mobiliser là
encore c'est beaucoup la violence
policière qui revient c'est quelque
chose qui nous a beaucoup choqués elles
sont jeunes elles n'ont jamais vu ça en
kong
donc pour elle c'est comme
une violation de leurs droits et elles
ont elles ont l'impression qu'il faut
qu'elles se mobilisent il faut qu'elles
participent à ces manipulations
enfin bref clément va pas garder toutes
ces entrevues mais quand on arrive comme
ça un endroit qu'on prenait pas beaucoup
c'est important de parler au plus de
monde possible donc longue journée pour
notre équipe dutil journal on a commencé
à 6 heures ce matin je me disais il est
presque 11 heures soit et là je crois
qu'il est temps que ça se termine donc
voilà on se reparle demain journée
numéro deux le madonna tournage a encore